hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Strange prequel video they
have a prequel comic that tees up what
some of the characters are doing so I'm
gonna explain that you know a little bit
of how magic works in the Marvel
Universe and also the funny thing about
this is they're introducing magic in the
MCU they're kind of shutting it down in
the comics it's called like the last
days of magic art but here we go Doctor
Strange movie for those of you that are
asking yes they're totally bringing
stuff to comic-con I don't know how much
of the cast is coming but I'm expecting
a new teaser to drop guardians of the
galaxy to is gonna be there
so they're gonna have like a big Marvel
panel they'll probably even bring a
little Avengers Infinity Ward stuff but
what the hell is going on in this Doctor
Strange comic so we're introduced to Maz
Nicholson's character and it kind of
sets up his relationship with the other
characters with long with the order of
magic that he belongs to the twist is
that cassellius is not evil in this
prequel comic so at some point in the
beginning or before Doctor Strange picks
up like immediately before the film he
turns bad so the a story of the comic is
basically them trying to chase down
someone who stole an artifact that
allows him to harness dark energy which
in the Marvel Universe is called zero
matter they actually used that is one of
the MacGuffin during the agent Carter TV
series during season two butkis ileus is
one of the disciples of the ancient one
just like Baron Mordo
we haven't met Doctor Strange yet like
the story of the movie is all about him
becoming sorcerer supreme and joining
the order so while all this stuff in the
prequel comic is happening he's still a
total douchebag doctor but the other
twist that I kind of brushed over a
little bit is that Baron Mordo is not
evil and he's not gonna be evil in the
movie either he's kind of like the
Winter Soldier Loki type character to
dr. Strange's Captain America Thor so
just like Loki and Thor fought like
brothers when the Thor movie picked up
then things got a little more
complicated that sounds like what's
going to be happening with Baron Mordo
in the future but not necessarily in
this first Doctor Strange movie which i
think is great it just gives them a
place to go in the future movie so what
it seems like is happening when they're
using magic is that it involves tapping
into energy from another dimension which
just sounds like a really trippy way for
people to tap into magic but I do like
that idea there's like a dimension
beyond arts like the dark dimension
which is part of the Doctor Strange
comics which
they can tap into they've also added
this visual component to it that kind of
looks like martial arts so that's
probably gonna look pretty cool you can
understand why they would visualize it
that way so that it's not just like
Gandalf pointing his finger at something
that's not quite as interesting given
some of the other stuff that we've seen
in the Marvel Universe I would expect
that that is some of the stuff that they
will show off in new Comic Con footage
like what it actually looks like when
they're weaving magic we learned that
Wong is just one of the other members of
the order he's not going to be dr.
Strange's manservant or anything like
that like he used to be in the comics
he's just gonna be another person in the
order like Baron Mordo Orca Silius they
introduced Daniel Drum whose brother in
the comics ends up becoming dr. voodoo
one of the future sorcerer Supremes
after dr. strange so they're definitely
ceding some really big stuff for this
Doctor Strange universe you have to
remember that each of these Avengers
level characters are franchises in and
of themselves so they kinda have to
build their own universe that exists
outside of the big team-up films so just
like Thor has Asgard all the people from
the Thor comics Doctor Strange has all
these mystical people from his comics so
they're gonna introduce a lot of them
and then finally we get a look inside
the sanctum sanctorum which actually
existed before dr. strange so it's not
like his super duper secret Clubhouse
before he becomes sorcerer supreme it
exists it holds a lot of magical
artifacts there gonna be a whole bunch
of Easter eggs so we'll have to keep our
eyes peeled when the film drops but if
you look back here you can see his cloak
of levitation so in addition to being
like a magical fortress it's also a
place where they keep a lot of artifacts
kind of like Odin's vault which just has
like a whole bunch of Easter eggs in it
sup so this will actually like looking
for Easter eggs in the sanctum sanctorum
will get you super hype for revisiting
Odin's vault in Thor Ragnarok so this is
the first issue of - the second one will
probably deal a little bit more with
Steven Strange's backstory along with co
Silius and why he split with the ancient
one and if you remember Tilda Swinton is
playing the ancient one in this she's
basically Tibetan that's the way they
explain it I can't wait to see how
Marvel deals with fing Fang Foom I don't
think they would ever do it in a million
years but I would love to see fing Fang
Foom show up during the Iron Fist series
because that is when you really start
getting into the mystic arts in the
daredevil universe but the really cool
thing about defenders is
the dr. strange was a member of
defenders in the comics so we might see
some Easter eggs going back and forth
but I'm not expecting any of the bigger
characters to cross over between
Daredevil and the movies anytime soon
like they even said Avengers infinity
war like the likelihood of a big
crossover is pretty slim
so don't you know don't hold your breath
for defenders characters being an
infinity war but that could change
anytime but let me know in the comments
like what do you guys want to see them
bring to comic-con from Doctor Strange
really I think the hardest job that they
have is to explain how magic works what
it looks like inside the Marvel Universe
because Loki has a certain form of magic
but in the comics it's a little
different from dr. Strange's form of
magic there's many different types of
magic in the comics I think the movies
are gonna try to simplify that a little
bit so I'm actually really excited you
know like whatever it ends up being it's
gonna look so trippy and so different
from anything we've seen in the Marvel
Universe before it is gonna be awesome
and Mads Mikkelsen is just gonna be
fantastic as the villain to Hannibal
Lecter's in the Marvel Universe now too
bad he's not gonna have any scenes with
Odin but if you guys do want to read
some more Doctor Strange comics they
have actually been teasing a new title
called Doctor Strange in the Sorcerer's
Supreme as in multiple sorcerers so I
think he's just gonna be a team-up Allah
last days of magic they like they've
been teasing people hunting down and
trying to destroy magic in the Marvel
Universe so Doctor Strange rallies all
the biggest magic users and that's gonna
be like their new book so it'll be Shama
and Scarlet Witch darker voodoo in
Doctor Strange so what's gonna happen
next week is I'm going to start doing
some more Comic Con videos I'll press
start doing a Marvel giveaway in
addition to the DC giveaway there's
always like a couple giveaways to happen
every week so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and if there's any like
specific comic-con videos or any comic
book videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments what
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my spider-man
homecoming behind the scenes video and
you can click here for new Suicide Squad
footage I talked a little bit about
Harley Quinn and Joker and Batman
thump - so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight